congressman Devin Nunez represents the
state of California he joins us tonight
thank so much for coming on this is not
your committee where the impeachment
drama started judiciary but you were
there today what was this about what did
it accomplish what was the point well I
think you could just keep going for the
rest of the show just like you're doing
that I'm enjoying watching that clip
from the lady from 2006 ever this is
this is totally nuts I don't know what
I'm watching I mean I walked in there
today I mean first of all you have to
ask yourself what the hell are those
people doing there yeah they don't have
any evidence we're here to impeach the
president well you should be putting
evidence on the table for what the
president did wrong and then when they
were asked direct questions do any of
you have evidence any evidence that's in
Adam shifts report to impeach the
president on they don't have any so you
have to ask yourself what the hell's
going on yeah I mean I I think they
think it's appealing to voters or
something I think most voters even most
Democrats despise the academic left the
academic left is disgusting and everyone
kind of feels that way yeah yeah and
these if you look at just I don't know
how anybody could even watch this today
and I'm not sure if anybody did watch
this I can't imagine what the ratings
are gonna be like and you know I guess
we'll know in the next couple days but
can you imagine people sitting through
that I mean that are at home watching I
just just kind of watching I know you've
talked about this but the new chairman
of your committee has Intel committee
somehow pulled the phone records of the
president's lawyers now we're going to
assess with an attorney in just a second
like whether that was even legal but my
question to you is how did he do that
and on what pretext how did this happen
so he has subpoena power so when the
Democrats gained control they have
subpoena power we knew he had issued he
notified us that he had subpoenaed some
phone numbers we didn't know who those
numbers were and of course because it's
in the skiff and it's classified we
can't talk about it I've started up
subpoenaed from home he subpoenaed from
AT&T phone record why would a teen teen
phone thumbs up that's a good question
that is a very I wouldn't he in teasing
us off you know I get to court AT&T
should have at least
went to court to try to see if what they
were gonna do was the right thing could
they do that for my phone records or
your phone records I mean it appears
like they could if Adam Schiff now wants
to go out and subpoena they've now set a
precedent where Adam Schiff can go and
get any phone number that he has send it
to AT&T and AT&T is gonna comply could
you get my email - I don't think that's
been tried but I assume be careful what
you wish for he could try it so what is
even worse is there a limit to his I
mean you ran the committee so you're
uniquely positioned answers but I'm not
sure a limit to his power I am not aware
of any previous time that we subpoenaed
phone records on the House Intelligence
Committee maybe before my time we did
but I find it very strange but then if
you look at what he did then it's not
just the president's phone records okay
or the president's lawyers phone records
he also was able to get a journalist the
journalist now John Solomon John Solomon
who they hate who they say is a
conspiracy theorist and he was able to
figure out that that was John Solomon's
phone number okay so now you have a
journalist involved then he was able to
get my number right and because I had
talked to Rudy Giuliani and somehow
that's now a crime and then I make it
into his report and we have to remember
I just want to back everybody up we
spent the last three years at first if
any Republican ever talked to any
Russian at any time even if you were
Russian American that was a that was a
no-no then we were criticized we
switched to Ukraine if you talk to any
Ukrainian that's now a crime now I can't
even talk to Rudy Giuliani who I've
known for ten years that's supposedly a
crime and I'm in his report for
supposedly doing something wrong so this
is this is wrong and what's happening is
whatever has happening in this town is
wrong and look I'm I'm going to look at
whatever legal remedies I have because I
actually have some civil rights here -
well then you watch you if they can do
this to you then like you know what
protection do we have they could do it
to you yeah I mean I call me a Russian
agent so yeah we'll be checking
congressman thanks so much for that
always a pleasure to see you thank you